[Music]
foreign
[Music]
like this Everything feels better calmer
as the natural rhythm of your breath
Settles
everyone in this Tai Chi class has
benefited from the care of nurses in the
NHS
they are fundamental to this country we
should be very proud being British
having the NHS service and they need to
be recognized the government could
actually
stop it couldn't they give them a decent
deal I don't know whether going on
strike will be of benefit in resolving
any of it or whether it may give them
um
that publicity
well not every part of West Yorkshire
will see industrial action the city of
Leeds will meaning disruption for every
generation doctors like Ahmed on a rare
day off with his son today will be
working even harder if anything happened
to Edina chase the first one was going
to be affected is the patient we will
try our best but I don't think we are
going to cover everything definitely
will be shortage in some areas
it's not long since the UK clapped the
carers
and for Maxine a nurse who was on the
covered Wards and held iPads up to
connect families with dying patients
this moment really hurts patients are
being put at risk every single day we
don't have enough staff to deliver the
care that patients need
um and it it's not it's not the care
that I would want and it's not the care
that I'd expect for any of my family
members how far are you willing to go
with this I'm willing to go as far as
needs to be to ensure safe Staffing and
better working conditions
she's lost counts of how many shifts
have ended in this kitchen with her
feeling broken not everyone agrees with
their decision to strike but it's a
decision that has now been taken Tom
Parmenter Sky News West Yorkshire